that's where we'll be  [Music]  hi yeah absolutely  my I've only been singing it since I was  like five I mean come on I'm Justice  John you really are dressed like gods  man this is perfect who doesn't know the  chorus there's all our training gets  better leading up to I can show you the  world shining shimmering splendid tell  me princess now when did you last let  your heart decide  I can open your eyes over sideways and  under on a magic carpet ride the new  Fantastic point of view no one to tell  us no or where to go or say we're only  dreaming  [Music]  sometimes you just have to take a risk  it was so excited to see it Jaffar he is  baked Will Smith being the genie  hands-down gonna be the best part why  damn do we need the top not that's my  little cherry on top  [Music]